we low so I apologize he's got Firearms
he got like a Uzi in his backpack it's a
Mac 10 and a n why did you bring it in
the courthouse we got Chase hold on hold
on before you do that did you read them
anything yet I haven't read them
anything I going to read you these real
quick because I don't want to be asking
you nothing uh you have the right ter
made silent any you say can will be used
against you in a court to law you're the
right to attorney if you cannot afford
an attorney one will be prived you do
you understand these rights of I read it
to you with these R in mind you would
you speak to me I got to read you those
because those are your all
right you want to put him in that that
lock down cell for
now we're going to go up this ramp
[Applause]
okay
what happened he can't he his Duff bag
he's got a Mac 10 and a
handgun have we done a complete search
of them no I haven't put them down yet
do that
we go to that
bench do you have anything on
you no I put no weapons nothing that's
going to poke to here cut me no all
right I'm going to do a pat down on you
real quick we're going to go right
here right here face
them are all these guns yours
yes all right put your hands
up Prett for
me that one's
[Music]
loaded the
fuck that one is
loaded
oh it's safe
oh
bro this is wild this is the wildest
thing I've ever seen in here what are
you here
for you're trying to file them I my
[Music]
M are you are you trying to file
restraining orders or what or you got
one place against you ain't nothing
against me like we hear a a whole bunch
of stuff anything happened in the last
year people relax anything is legal in
my name and my um okay but you can't
bring this in here I know everything
happen so we getting chased I got
dropped off by by Officer officer Gates
bash number 141 we just came on the
hospital they know everything already
but you had inside a hospital too yes
everything happens you had both of these
weapons inside of a hospital yes they
took me to the backb and everything
Christ everything just happened a couple
seconds Cleveland brought you down here
with no like the hospital the hospital D
it's like what hospital it's like 5
minutes away 6 minutes away which
hospital though I I don't know you don't
know which hospital you were at
everything happens up the hospital is
like 6 minutes away bus wise what side
of town this side east side or west
side
I
got what say no it's literally like down
the street if you take the bus we just
came like the backs St Vincent Yes St V
you went to St Vincent and they brought
you over here with two guns no we went
to the hospital and they dropped us off
dropped us off
because I know I can't bring it in here
but everything is so dangerous right now
I can't loose it
up so the Poli an ID on
you it's it's on in my phone it's in
your phone yeah like my
phone do you have a phone over here
no where's your phone at might still all
be down there did your did you put it in
a bed yes all right give me a minute
what kind of phone is it what color it's
red iPhone 8 does one of you guys want
to go down there andge and see if you
can
[Music]
get
sh 77 radio
time you got one
two three four
$42 you got $1 coin thank four quarter
four quarters I really can't answer that
question cuz it's not my points it's my
mom's well it's on it's in your property
so it's going to go with you okay so I'm
just making sure you see what we're
going to put in there
okay and then 2 cents okay there's 50
there's 90 there's a
dollar so 402 okay making sure I just
want to make sure
you can't say that anybody took any of
your
money this is what came out of your
black bag here okay
okay
[Applause]
any other monary value property
or I just put
[Music]
clothes clothes back in here
magazines got a like a CD case that
okay I'll stick that back in
here walk with him
down body
products
uh cell phone
charger he's memor right y uh understood
right um what is uh what What's his
purpose for being here today protection
order you said a protection order his
mom's somewhere in the building you said
right she here to file the protection
order let's send let's send somebody up
to
eight um try and find Mom
I
[Music]
okay
what's your mom
wearing know what she's
wearing not really
no said she want the file protection
order yeah she
somewhere she here
up you don't know they got when I first
came in here I I was trying to talk to
the female officer I like before I Ste
in I got something but everything think
was happening so fast in the line that
she ain't hear me so I steep back so I
put it in anyway because everything
that's going on I put it
in is your mom on probation no she got a
criminal case no so what was she here
for then your mom a lot like
what well I mean what' you guys come
down here for today you know you know
I'm asking for for what was the main
purpose of you come down
here we we was getting chased sh chased
by who X her ex she's getting chased by
her ex okay you know what color shirt
she had
on a white
shirt did it have any writing on it no
no just plain white T-shirt shirt is it
a tank top is it a like a short sleeve
shirt is it a long sleeve shirt like a
short
sleeve she has glasses right glasses yes
and a bunch of jewelry
yes I can't remember what pants was was
she wearing like khakis or like greenish
what is it like greenish yeah but
they're like pants
like she have long hair short hair I
think was short
is it like is it cut up or is it long
short like cut up she got like green
like green khakis
on green
khakis okay what color shoes do she have
on do you know white shoes black shoes
red shoes blue shoes she have high heels
on she have tennis shoes on
slippers shoes on what are you looking
for diet program might be they might
might be in the try the try the room
over there cuz I saw this table set up
how old is she overweight yeah 47 I
need I don't
have we got everybody up here
okay she's going to have to write her
hey LT she's got to she's got to
type
okay does she walk with a cane walk with
anything no
okay I want something I
know be
SP yeah what is she here for you
said like where would she go I don't
know the story The the story is so deep
like what's about to come out I rather
for y'all to talk to her about that the
story is deep what do you mean by the
story is deep
here2 I'm just asking what what do you
mean my story is deep you said it not me
I know but anything's scary right now I
mean there ain't nobody in here going to
get
you we've been get when uh I turn my
head like that because we're getting
chased by by multiple people I don't
know if that was one of the people I
don't know it's multiple people like
they got Lookouts that's why I took my
hair like that they got a look out yes
we getting chased by multiple cars
that's why if y'all notice I turned my
head because I don't know who is who
like
there
you ever find his
phone did your mom take your phone I
don't
know I put in I put in a tray I was
trying to tell the female officer down I
had the guns in my bag and that's
everybody
want
does your mom have a
purse I think so think
so that's what is the pur I'm wondering
if that's all her stuff
that's yeah all the first and everything
that's all their stuff mom
stuff did we take these out anym uh when
they get
downstairs
yeah
you don't got a bell on do you you got
any other property on you my
man any
jewelry get
that to see if I can find spend the next
minutes go put your shoe on
[Applause]
there
all right
thanks watch
[Music]
okay what's up
with right there go in front of the the
security SC you scanners and it's right
there
watch
I'm walking down
with spin around there buddy one more
time yeah nothing else on you bud go
separate your feet all right yeah kick
your legs apart
okay keep your legs probably a little
further okay
that was on the SRI this quick I'm
a just throw in the drawer
okay whatever
[Music]
just so you know
radio charged for the commands of the
weapons in the adjust Center
okay there's numerous signs on the doors
and all that can't bring that in all
right you understand I'm not going to
sit here and Li you and tell you you
know you're not but fortunately
do to your action we got to charge you
okay all
right
good is this I'm assuming you're giving
it to the books yeah his
property all right we're going to walk
this way
okay these elevator over here to the
right